foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to our webinar today
addressing the challenges of membrane
protein sample preparation for cryoheum
analysis my name is Edward Pryor from
Thermo Fisher Scientific and I'll be
your host for today
our first Speaker Dr Matthews Ramen is
an r d staff scientist at Thermo Fisher
and will be presenting the overall
workflow of single particle cryo-em
sample preparation
specifically discussing the challenges
of membrane protein sample prep and
sharing strategy and best practices to
improve the success rate of sample
preparation and obtain high quality
cryo-em results
following this presentation our featured
speaker Dr Rosemary cater an associate
research scientist at Columbia
University will discuss an approach used
to solve structures of small membrane
proteins using cryo-em where she
complexes Target proteins with specific
monoclonal antigen binding fragments to
increase particle size and provide
fiducials outside of the transmembrane
region for alignment
she'll describe how her and her lab used
this approach to determine the cryo-em
structure of the major facility major
facilitator super family domain
containing 2A which has a molecular
weight of 58 kilodons to a resolution of
3.0 angstroms
we'll conclude these presentations with
a q a session where the three of us will
answer any questions you might have
regarding topics presented in today's
webinar
before we jump into mafusa's
presentation I wanted to quickly just
set the stage for today's presentations
in early 2021
along with Rosie's Lab at Columbia
University we published a meta-analysis
of membrane protein structural biology
where we looked at structure
determination techniques used across the
last 10 years
in 2019 you can see by this chart was
the first year where the number of crow
em membrane protein structures
determined by cryo-em eclipsed the
number of protein structures determined
by x-ray crystallography
what's really exciting to show is that
in the years that follow in 2020 and
2021 this number is significantly
increased and so as you can see if we
add in the last two years of data to
this graph you could see that the
majority of structures determine the the
majority of unique membrane protein
structures determined by cryo-em
significantly uh
eclipses the number determined by x-ray
crystallography
I don't have the data from 2022 yet
processed to be put in this graph but a
quick analysis shows that this number
continues to increase and that close to
90 percent of the unique membrane
protein structures determined by cryo
were determined by cryo-em in 2020 to
to why this increase well we're seeing
that this increases due to more cry-em
accessibility
increased throughput of the experiment
and really the focus of today's webinar
improves sample preparation techniques
for membrane proteins
so what's next
if we look at all of the structures in
the pdb Richard Henderson proposes that
by 2024 cryoem will be the predominant
method for all proteins deposited in the
pdb so where are we today so at last
look in 2022 we're currently about 64 of
the structures that were determined or
deposited in 2022 were determined by
x-ray crystallography with about 34
percent by Crow em and if we look at a a
recent tweet or a recent graph from uh
masakiwa uh he shows that yes even at
the current trends we are projected to
hit this number in 2024 as predicted by
Richard Henderson
so with that just to set the stage I'll
turn it over to my first Ramen who will
be talking about tools and strategies
for improving sample preparation for for
membrane proteins
all right thanks Eddie for the
introduction during my PST and
postdoctoral training I worked with
several challenging membrane proteins
and based on my experience I will
discuss on the power of cry em and some
challenges related to the trium sample
prep and a simple sample optimization
method
in 2017 when I was in my fourth year of
doctoral studies there was a huge
recognition in the structural biology
field for developing tri-electron
microscopy
the Nobel Prize was shared among double
share Frank and Henderson
developed a method to keep the
biomolecules in solution for chiom
application
he flash froze the biological sample in
liquid Ethan where the liquid water
solidified in its liquid form
surrounding the biomolecules and
retained the same condition as in the
solution
prank developed an image processing
method to merge electron microscopes
fuzzy 2D images to produce a sharp
three-dimensional structure
in 1990 Henderson succeeded in using an
electron microscope to generate a
three-dimensional image of a protein
and following these discoveries with the
advancement in instruments and Sample
preparation methods the desired Atomic
resolution was released in 2013.
now researcher can routinely obtain high
resolution structure of biomolecules
using cry em
during my PhD I was using extra
crystallography to study the structural
biology of an ABC transporter at Rick
and spring at Center in Japan the
largest synchronous facility over there
in 2018 I visited San Francisco to
present my crystal structure at
biophysical Society in that conference I
was hearing a lot of success stories of
membrane proteins using critium
at that time there was very limited
scope of crime in Japan
in the same conference I also met my
postdoctoral mentor Dr Ryan Hipps so I
moved to USA to continue working on
membrane protein structural biology and
to learn single particle cry yeah
during my postdoc I was working with the
league Channel called nicotinic receptor
the picture says it all and it took
several years from my PhD to solve one
crystal structure of this ABC
transporter
and to solve three different
confirmation of this transporter it took
around 10 years from my PhD love from
three different members
on the other hand in my fourth years of
postdoctoral work I determined eight
high resolution structure of this ION
channel in large conformational steps
so this is today is not only my story
the same story goes for most membrane
protein is textual biologist
to cry and feel the huge gap in the
structural biology of membrane protein
and protein complexes
method is limited to detergent and
lipidy cubic phase and in both cases the
membrane portion of the protein are not
available to make direct Crystal packing
and also in the presence of detergent
caused the high solvent content which
causes fragile crystals or low
diffracted crystals
and also in many cases we could see the
anisotropy in the data
on the other hand crime offers a
structure in Native like step
moreover
the crystals in the crystals protein are
static or rigid although ligand soaking
is an excellent method but the crystal
will break if there is any significant
structural chance
in the aquarium sample the proteins are
in solution and dynamic to adopt any
conformations
this sellers gives an overview of the
single particle cryum workflow the
sample creation include the expression
extraction and purification of the
protein
and the protein biochemistry need to be
optimized to ensure that the purified
protein is functional
in the verification step we will add our
protein sample to the grates and flush
freeze in liquid ethane using feed robot
The Next Step will be to screen the
grades to look at the different
parameters to decide whether to optimize
the biological sample of proteins
further or to go for data collection
and processing the EM images will
produce a 3D map which will be used to
build the atomic model
in this process every step is critical
and important and in many cases need
optimization
so what does a native like state mean I
will give the example of my postdoctoral
work
on ligand-gated ION channels the
membrane proteins are embedded in the
lipid bilayer of cell membrane and
therefore the lipids are very important
for their stability and function
faster purified the protein using
detergent then I remove the detergent
and again reconstrated the protein back
to lipid by layer
and check their ION channel function
using electrophysiology
after finding suitable lipids for
function I reconstituted the protein in
those lipids in presence of scaffold
protein for structural analysis
this is a 3D cry-em map in low
resolution showing that the lipid
nanotis is surrounding the membrane
portion of the protein which mimics the
native like step
we study the membrane proteins the first
step we must extract them from the
membrane which is typically done by
using detergent and thermoficious
scientific offers various detergents
including TDM Elementary
and OJ OTG and Digitonin among them TDM
and lmng is also available in
combination with CHS
we also offer some classical detergent
like Triton Breeze and twin
in my next slide I will talk about the
gpcr extraction and stabilization
reagent
to support the protein purification
we have Affinity regime and magnetic
beads for various stacks like the histag
and Dyk dddk which is commonly known as
flag tag and GST tag m4hf
for grid preparation we have a training
kit that includes almost everything to
start with grid freezing
and that is also including a standard
protein app version
in my later talk I will discuss on a
buffer schooling kit for sample
optimization during petrification
and we also offer the negative extending
Solutions
for vitrification with some of
scientific offer peterbot mark IV
so gpcr are one of the important drug
targets and in many cases the receptor
are not functional after extraction and
purification in detergent
after screening various detergent and
stabilization agent we offer an
all-in-one solution to extracts the gpcr
also ensure the protein is functional
the reagent demonstrate an excellent
extraction profile from both cell and
tissue sources
we also offer an antibody that could be
used to establish the gpcrg protein
complex in active step
petrification process is a part of
sample prep challenge in cry-em
if an epidified protein with nice
biochemistry can we have differently in
a thin features ice layer
istickness is important for the
resolution
is like this is desirable but the thick
ice will cause adverse effect on the MS
contrast and thus limit the resolution
another major problem leading
fitification is protein aggregation
ideally the particle should be
monodispersed and separated from each
other so for a high resolution data a
nice particle distribution is ideally
needed
prefer a nutrition of the particles is a
recurring problem in this field the left
figure
is showing a 2d class of a data where
the side view is only present
in an ideal data for high dissolutionary
structure information particle should
add up random orientation
to solve this problem multiple rounds of
optimization is often necessary
currently septum sample optimization is
mostly performed in a non-systemic way
like changing grid types or changing the
plotting force or plotting time or using
different detergent for protein
purification or different soil
concentration
and we also add Define detergent to
solve the preferred orientation problem
and this optimization takes more days or
weeks to find weeks to optimize the
proteins
to reduce this we have developed a
buffer screening kit with a broad range
of pH and salt concentration and they
are ready to use the kit contains 14
buffers and six detergent selected from
over 800 Prime papers published from
2014-19
a white paper is available with a
detailed method on how to use this
screening kit systematically identify
the best condition for pystification
for a specific protein please make sure
to check this white paper
this figure is from the white paper
showing that buffer screening was
helpful to find the best condition for
20s protea jump
the impact on unsuitable Buffer range
from protein aggregation Port particle
distribution or prefer orientation
another example from the paper showing
that the detergent screening was helpful
to solve the preferred orientation
problem for Coronavirus spec protein
the screening workflow is very simple
and only need one working day
it involves the use of fit robot and
microscope with the epu multi-grid
software which enables automatic data
collection for 12 grades in a day
two round of screening is recommended
first round to select these outputs in
concentration and the charge of buffer
the second round is to select the
detergent in both cases it is recommend
to check the biochemistry with the added
buffer or detergent
and also keep in mind to avoid glycerol
sugars or high concentration of salt in
the cryium sample buffer because those
compounds can have adverse effects on
the petrification or image quality
epipheritin is being widely used and as
standard protein for single particle cry
M the application of effortin includes
microscope calibration workflow
validation method development
so and we are happy to share that we are
supplying appropriate in as ready to
apply on the crates the sample is 97
percent pure
and consistently providing high
resolution data the highest resolution
we obtained was
1.79 strong resolution
if you are new to cry em and want to
learn the workflow it is a commentary
start your training with F18
to sum up I have talked about the
protein prayer focusing on cryamp
and I discussed on the related
challenges during the purification and a
simple screening method for the
optimization
almost everything from my talk is
available in our website and in the
white paper
as a product we have effort in standard
buffer screening kit training kit and
negative strengths
the presented Works were done in a
collaboration between Rockford einhoven
and San Jose side of therm official
scientific I am based in Rockford site
and I would like to thank Joanna Aaron
Barb K and Chris
all the microscopy work was done at I
know Ben site from that side dimple
Atiya Natalia Albert and Eddie was
involved in this project and thanks to
Roja and watching from San Jose side for
massive spectroscopy support
I would like to close my presentation
thank you everyone for your attention
thank you mafus for that great
presentation
now we'll turn the presentation over to
Dr Rosemary cater who will be talking
about her work on the MFS d2a protein
okay so today I'm going to
come to you about an approach that
myself and a number of other people in
the Mantra Lab at Columbia University
have been using to solve the cryium
structures of small membrane proteins
using query
so almost 75 of the human proteome is
made up of proteins that are less than
50 kilodaltons in size
and despite them serving in a vast array
of important biological functions they
only make up about 1.3 percent of
proteins within the EM data bank and
it's not because they're not interesting
proteins it's not because no one's
studying them it's just because they're
still technically challenge it's still
technically challenging to determine the
structures of these proteins using
queryum
and this is for a number of different
reasons firstly because purely because
of the size of these they have a low
signal to noise ratio and also because
um these proteins typically lack
distinctive tertiary features that allow
us to align particles in the data
processing pipeline
it's important to note that
um these two problems are even worse for
membrane proteins because a lot of that
signal gets buried within either a
detergent myself or a lipid bilayer for
structural determination so it just sort
of exacerbates the issue
so today I'm going to talk to you about
how I overcame some of these issues
um using antibody binding technology to
determine the structure of a small
membrane protein that transports fish
oil from the blood into the brain
and so we'll have heard of fish oil we
all have been told it's good for us but
what exactly is it and what does it do
and how does it get to where it's needed
in the body
so fish oil is made up of three
different types of omega-3 fatty acids
and the one that I'm going to talk to
you about today is called don't go to
hexanoic acid or DHA
so DHA has this chemical structure here
it's got a charged or polar head group
and a long hydrophobic polyunsaturated
tail
and it's found in really high
concentrations in the brain so it
actually makes up about five percent of
the total weight of a neuronal cell
membrane and so as you can imagine it's
completely essential for proper neuronal
development functioning and aging
now despite this dependence that we that
the brain has for DHA it can actually
make DHA and we can make a small amount
of it in the liver but we actually
heavily rely on dietary sources of DHEA
in order to fuel our brain
now of course to get this DHA into the
brain it needs to cross the blood-brain
barrier so just to remind you of what
that is it's a layer of tightly packed
endothelial cells that separate the
blood from the brain parenchyma
and it exists of course to protect our
brain from neurotoxins however it also
creates a major bottleneck in
neurotherapeutic development
so in order to get DHA into the brain we
have these DHA Transporters that are
called mfsd2a that are highly expressed
in the microvasculature of the brain and
were first characterized by David Silva
and his team at Duke and us in 2014.
and what their team demonstrated is that
if you knock out this transporter in a
mouse model that you get significant
reductions of DHEA uptake into the brain
and severe microcephaly and phenotypes
that are reminiscent of omega-3 fatty oh
sorry of um
omega-3 fatty acid deficits
so as the name implies mfsd2a is a
member of the major facilitator super
family or MFS of transporters
and we're really lucky that there are a
lot of Crystal structures of members of
this transporter family that have taught
us a lot about the mechanisms that they
use to shuttle solutes across the
membrane
so we know that they are typically made
up of 12 transmembrane helices and that
these are separated into two six Helix
bundles The n-terminal Domain in blue
and the C terminal domain in red and
that they use what's called a rocker
switch mechanism to shuttle substrates
across the membrane so you can see on
the left that the transporter starts off
in an outward facing v-shape which
provides substrate and co-transported
ions access to a central binding site
and that once they've bound there's a
conformational change and the
transporter then shifts to being in an
inward facing conformation where the
substrate can then be released to the
other side of the membrane
so while we now know a fair bit about
how this family of Transporters work
it's important to remember that the
crystal structures that we had available
are of ones that transport small and
relatively hydrophilic molecules the
substrate of mfsd2a is
um completely different it's got this
large large multivalent head group and
this floppy hydrophobic tail and so it's
reasonable to consider that the
mechanism by which this transporter
transports this substrate may be
somewhat unique and the membrane itself
might actually be involved in that and
so we were really interested in
understanding the structural basis of
this
so some of you may have just noticed
that the substrate I just put up there
for mfsd2a isn't just DHA it's actually
DHA that's been esterified with the
lysophosphatidylcholine or LPC head
group and so this is a laser lipid
substrate
and this esterification is completely
essential for uptake into the brain
however mfsd2a can transport a number of
different lizolipids you just need to
have a multivalent head group and
um at least 14 carbons in the tail and
preferably some degree of unsaturation
so go into this project we didn't have a
lot of information about how this
transporter works we did know that in
the blood lpcdha is carried around by
albumin and we hypothesize that it gets
inserted into the outer leaflet of the
membrane and then that mfsd2a flips that
lipid to the other side of the membrane
in a sodium dependent fashion
so as I said I'm really interested in
understanding the structural
um basis of this transport not only
because it serves a really important
physiological function and it's very
biophysically interesting we don't know
a lot about lizolipid transport
um but also because if we can understand
how mfsd2a transports LPC DHA into the
brain then we can use this information
to develop neurotherapeutics so they can
hijack the system and enter the brain um
in the same fashion
so starting off this project I actually
started it um in 2017 which was a while
ago now and and back then I chose to
start doing it using uh crystallography
because it was this protein is only 58
kilodaltons in size and so not really in
the range for cryo-em
and because this is a membrane protein
and they're often quite difficult to
express
um the way that I started off this
project is by screening expression of a
number of different mfsd2a orthologs
from different species that are have a
good sequence similarity to to that of
the human
um with it fused to a gfp tag to see
which
um which ortholog is stable and high
expressing and as you can see here some
Express well some don't and from this we
move forward with the mfsd2a gallus
gallus construct as we could see that it
was our highest expressing construct
we then went forward and did a um
detergent screen so where we screen
um stability of our protein in a range
of different
um detergents and this is because as you
can see here
um different membrane proteins are more
stable and can have their structure
determined
um in a range of different
uh detergent
um
environments and so we're not in order
to do this we're then took our mfsd2a
gallus gallus and tried it in a range of
different detergents and it actually
tolerated a lot of them fairly well but
that with DDM thf was the best and the
sharper says DDM supplemented with
cholesterol hemisoxinate
um and so we move forward with that
um of course we wanted to check that
this transporter was functional which we
we first did and once confirming that
um we then went and amped up the
um expression of this protein using a
baccala virus system we optimized our
purification strategy and from that we
went and lay um some Crystal trees
oh we never got any crystals which is
not an uncommon story in this field
um and our first hypothesis was was that
this is because
um this protein actually has two
glycosylation sites and um that can
inhibit Crystal formation and so we then
when I mutated out these sites but that
actually those mutations actually
reduced
um our expression of this protein quite
substantially to a point where we were
pretty pessimistic if we'd ever be able
to get enough protein for
um lean Crystal trees
and so it was at this stage of the
project that we started to consider if
maybe cryo em could help us because we
we know that over the last 10 years the
usage of cryo-em to solve membrane
proteins has dramatically increased to a
point where it now overtakes that of um
X-ray crystallography and that the
resolution average resolution of these
structures is improving every single
year
in addition to that we also know that
the
um size of the proteins that we can
solve using membrane proteins this is
for by the way
um using query m is decreasing every
year so in the light blue and the dark
blue down the bottom you can see that
proteins beneath 200 and even 100
kilodaltons
um are being solved with increasing
um propensity every year
so with this we decided to give um
cryo-em a shot and another reason why we
were really excited to do that is
because it gave us the opportunity to
reconstitute our protein and in Nano
disk so that's a sort of a nano disc of
um
a membrane bilayer that's surrounded by
an amphipathic membrane scaffold protein
and so it sort of is a membrane memetic
and you can see here that it's a
somewhat popular choice still not the
main choice but a lot of people do do
this
um to determine
um membrane protein structures using cry
OEM and for us it was really important
because remember our substrate is Eliza
lipid and we predicted the lipid made
the lipid bilayer may be involved in
um the substrate transport process and
so this was great for us
and so after
um
after optimizing this reconstitution
process
um we then made some grids of the
protein and did some screening and while
this is just a screen it's not a high
resolution collection when we saw this
and we didn't see any transmembrane
helices we see essentially nothing
sticking out of the membrane
um is essentially it looked like a UFO
to us and so we're pretty pessimistic
that would be able to get any high
resolution information from these
particles
and so it was at this stage of the
project that we started to collaborate
with the lab of Tony cosiakov and his
postdoc Satchel at the University of
Chicago and what um Tony flab has
developed is this library of um
synthetic Fabs
um and that using um using phage display
you can screen your protein against this
library to pull out ones that find
specifically to your protein of interest
and so this does two things to help with
structure determination using Pro OEM
first of all it bulks up the size of
your protein so we've gone from 58 to
108 kilodolphins in this case which
gives us more signal but also it gives
us an extra membrane feature to align
our particles here and tell us you know
which way the particle is actually
facing what weighs up or weighs down and
then align our particles more
efficiently
I just put this slide in here just to
point out
um that using antibodies isn't the only
strategy for giving yourself a fiducial
um people also use nanobodies or as you
can see here there are a range of
different strategies to do this which
has been reviewed really nicely by when
to get all um in current research in
structural biologies just last year and
so here you can see there's a number of
different strategies including the
nabfab system the mega body system the
Lego body system and a range of Target
infusion strategies
um to give yourself an opportunity to
get a fiducial to get you that high
resolution
um aquarium structure you're after
so after we were able to confirm complex
formation without Fab of choice we then
had a and perform some screening and
then had a high resolution
um a collection on the krios microscope
and from that we were able to get these
2D class averages which we were really
excited about because as you can see
here you've got individual transmembrane
helices
um within the nanodisc cloud and the Fab
sticking out into the soluble space in
lots of different orientations available
to us
and so from this we were able to obtain
a three angstrom reconstruction of MFS
d2a and you've got the n-terminal domain
in blue the fee terminal domain in pink
and the variable domain of the Fab up
here on the outside of the membrane
and into that we were able to build our
structure of mfsd2a as you can see here
it has a classic NFS d2e a sorry it has
a classic MFS fold so 12 transmembrane
helices separated into two six Helix
bundles and here you can see it's in
this upside down v-shape so that's the
inward facing conformation so you've
actually got this large intracellular
cavity inside which Harbors the number
of interesting features that I'll just
show you very quickly
um so I want you to imagine that you're
standing in the middle of that
intracellular cavity and you're looking
left and you're seeing everything
contributed from the n-terminal domain
and then you're looking right and seeing
everything contributed from the c
channel domain and the first thing you
notice is that it's very antipathic so
residues from the n-terminal domain are
relatively hydrophilic or charged and
those from the C terminal domain are
more hydrophobic
they're looking at that end terminal
domain in more detail now we saw a
couple of interesting features so up the
top of
um the cavity contributed from the
n-terminal domain we can see that
there's this charge central region so
there's a bunch of charged or
hydrophilic residues and it's actually
directly adjacent to the sodium binding
site which would provide um an ability
for the coupling mechanism and we
thought this site looks really perfect
for binding lizolipid head groups of our
substrate
of course we wanted to confirm that
these were functionally important and so
we did that in collaboration with David
Silva and I'm not going to go through
all of the data now but we saw some that
these a number of these especially this
e312 was particularly important for
transport
looking at the c-terminal Domain in more
detail we saw something really
interesting so we saw that there's this
deep pocket that's lined by hydrophobic
residues that I've highlighted in pink
so this is just two different views of
that pocket and when we saw this we
thought it looks really perfect for
binding Eliza lipid tail and what was
even more interesting is that we saw
that within this pocket there was
aquarium density that we couldn't
attribute to substrate sorry that we
couldn't attribute to protein and so
um when we saw this we thought have we
captured a substrate in a binding pocket
that just came from our expression
system which in this case was insect
cells
and so in order to determine that we
sent our sample to Michael Marty and
Michael's grad student James Keena
performs native Mass Effect on this um
sample and demonstrated that I actually
had a 515 Dalton molecule bound to a
subset of the particles present within
um the sample now 515 Daltons is a
molecular weight of LPC 18 3 which we
also know it's a substrate for mfsd2a
and so with that information we then
built in that um LPC 183 into the
density and as you can see it fits
relatively nicely and matches up with
the chemistry
of course we wanted to make sure that
these residues were functionally
important and so
um we mutated them and had a range of
different effects essentially if you
change the bulk or the charge of the
residue then you abrogate transport
and so when we have this substrate bound
um if we look at the middle picture we
can see that the the head group is sort
of poking out
um in between this Gap where the the
Liza lipid head group is sort of
interacting with the phosphate head
groups of the um inner leaflet of the
bilayer and so it really looks like it's
poised to be released into that in the
leaflet of the bilayer and so in order
to investigate that uh we could we
started to collaborate with George
kalash Philly and what George did is he
ran molecular Dynamic stimulations of
this protein and a range of different
um conditions and demonstrated that in a
sodium dependent manner the laser lipid
could move through this Gateway between
teams five and eight into the lipid um
bilayer so it's actually this lateral
Gateway that provides a substrate with
um access and it will access to the
membrane and exit from the protein
and so from this data and more we were
able to propose this mechanism for
mfsd2a mediated transport which I'm not
going to go through in detail now but if
you want to read more about it then we
published it in nature in um June 2021
and what's also really nice is that
since we put out this structure there
are now a number of other MFS d2e
structures that have come out
subsequently or cryo-em structures all
ones that either use antibody binding
technology nanobodied Tech binding
technology or other extra membrane
binding Partners um binding to this
um transporter that have allowed for
this cryo-em structure determination and
it's taught us a lot about how this
transporter mediates
um
mediates uptake of laser lipids across
this um lipid bilayer and this is all
thanks to these sorts of technologies
that give us a fiducial to allow for
chromium structure determination
and I'd also just want to point out that
it this isn't just for one transporter
in our lab alone we've now used this
technology to solve the structures of
um a range of other even smaller
um integral membrane proteins
um all to a relatively good resolution
which is fantastic it's a really
powerful technology and with that I'd
like to thank my mentor Felipe mancha
um for everything that he's taught me
and everything in the lab and the whole
team and also for Ollie Clark for
teaching me
everything about proem data processing
all of our collaborators and our cryo
wem facility staff
um and also to all our funding agencies
and thank you for your attention
all right thank you Rosie and Matthews
for those great presentations uh now
we've come to the live q a portion of uh
of this webinar so if you have any
questions and if you have already
started coming in for our presenters uh
if you do have any questions there is a
q a button on the lower left hand corner
of your uh of your window and maybe
we'll just kick it off uh first question
maybe for Rosie
um so
let's see let me just actually find this
quite there we go uh so you in terms of
the uh the Fabs that you uh added to
your protein are there any concerns or
issues with those disassociating from uh
from the protein of Interest
hi Eddie
um yes uh there can be in some cases
it's I mean these are high Affinity the
majority of the time they're on the
nanamola
um scale
um however a range of and we typically
add them at a three to one ratio to our
protein so we are already adding them in
excess
but um you can get um dissociation of
the complex as you can with any complex
um we've found that adding
um sort of detergent molecules or
antipathic molecules because I mean this
is due to air water interface issue
right so if we add on some empty Pole or
some chaps or some glycerizic acid
um or floral octal multicide and those
are some of the
um
antibody molecules that we found that
can prevent dissociation of particles
because of that air water interface
great maybe one additional follow-up
question to that or a related question
that that has come in uh so the the the
structure you determined was uh was done
in nanodiscs does the does this always
have to be done in nanodisks for in
order for this strategy to work of uh of
adding Fabs to the Target protein or can
be done in other membrane memetics
right so for this screening platform
because they threw in the in Chicago
they're three in the library against uh
using phase display and so in this case
um we reconstituted into biotinylated
nanoes so that we can immobilize them on
the plate
um
so you need some sort of bioclination
there to immobilize it they have also
done in it in um biogenylated amphipol
you can also get and you can um use that
as well
um but yeah you need for this for this
specific sort of um f8 this specific Fab
approach you would need it to be
um in Nano just for the screening but as
to whether those antibodies that you
obtain in nanodisk also bind in other
memetics
um I think it's probably quite likely
that it has it's not something that I've
actually tested myself but I'd be really
interested to do that actually because
sometimes it can be beneficial to not
have your protein analogous to get
around some other issues
sounds like a follow-up question but uh
we will maybe pause and uh
pass over to tumafu so uh
you talked a little bit about uh the APO
ferritin standard and I know this is
this is focused on membrane proteins but
there was a question that came in about
the APO ferritin standard uh do you
users have to do anything to that
protein is there any pre-work that needs
to be done before uh before applying
that sample to a grid
yeah thanks Eddie for the question
so no the short answer and we optimize
everything including concentration and
buffer conditions so there is no issue
of aggregation so you can directly apply
to the grades
thanks
uh let's see here's a I think there's
about five questions in one in this one
let me see if we can we can parse them
out here
um maybe I'll ask the uh first one to
Rosie when reconstituting uh proteins
into nanodiscs how do you choose the
correct lipid composition and and maybe
even a step further the correct lipid
ratio for for nanodisk reconstitution
um so that's a great question because it
is an issue I know we always talk about
how we don't need much protein for
um cry OEM but when you're trying to
um decide these ratios and the lipid
composition you really want to perform a
screen so the way that I do this is I
and obviously that's going to work
better if you have oh it's going to be
more
um achievable if you have more protein
to do the screen although we do it on
smaller scales I'm just using an hblc we
um
try a range of different lipid molecules
a range of different mfp
um proteins
um at a range of different ratios
um so we screen all of those different
conditions because I don't think that
there is really a simple answer every
protein is going to want a different
makeup
great all right still parsing apart this
one question uh the second part I think
is to you mafus uh is the gpcr
extraction and stabilization kit that
you talked about applicable for other
types of membrane proteins or other
classes of membrane proteins
so at first we we tested on the mainly
for the gpcrs and later we tested for
other medium proteins and we have data
that shows that also did a great
extraction profile for other membrane
proteins we are still working on it to
optimize for many membrane proteins and
to recommend it for all of the memory
proteins but from my experiments yes it
can be applicable for all the membrane
proteins but it depends on protein to
protein
great
I like this question because I have a
feeling that all three of us will answer
this question differently uh so I'll ask
it and thankfully I don't actually have
to answer it so uh
the premise of this question is uh I'd
like to know how essential detergent
exchange is during purification uh and
I'll ask this maybe to you Rosie first
and then to mafu second in your opinion
is it a good idea to use a single
detergent for both solubilization and
purification
um well uh that's an interesting it's
going to be different depending on your
protein right and actually we put out a
review on this uh 2020 I think one of
those fun covered projects
um where we
um compared the different detergents the
different protein families that the one
that I put up for you
um within my talk that had the different
protein families and the different
um
detergents that we use that was for the
structure determination condition but we
actually also analyzed the different
um detergents that we use for
solubilization and how often an exchange
is so I think that's probably the best
place to go and look for your specific
protein of interest
um to get a guide as to where to go
um yeah
so yeah I'll uh let's see if my
hypothesis holds true that we'll answer
this all differently uh in your opinion
is it a good idea to use a single
detergent for both solubilization and
purification
and that is the great question and
actually it's depends on the protein but
I will answer it differently that the
lipids are very important for the
membrane protein and when there is a
harsh detergent that is the problematic
but also if you want to extract nicely
from the native tissue Source or from
the cell
you sometimes might want to use the
harsh detergent to do the extraction
better and at that time around the
membrane protein there is all of the
lipids is surrounding so there is little
harm compared to the after you purified
it
so after purification yes always
recommend the mild detergent but for the
extraction job if you want to use little
bit harshita there that is okay most of
the cases but it's depend on the protein
to protein and how much is the inter
solar domain
is flexibility of the protein so it
depends on manufacture but sounding when
in presence of lipid little bit harsh
detergent I will not mind for my
postdoctoral work I use Triton that is
very harsh detergent to extract from the
Native membrane and then I exchange to
DDM which is milder detergent so it
depends on the protein but it is no harm
to do any detergent exchange from my
opinion
thanks
thank you both and since I really can't
help myself I do have to throw an
opinion on this
uh yeah I think I agree with both of you
that it absolutely depends on the
protein of interest but I also think
another factor is that it also depends
on the uh the end sort of goal of what
you want to do with that protein whether
it's structure determination by extra
crystallography or structured
determination by cryo-em or functional
assays I think that has a huge choice in
in the final detergent that you choose
to to put your protein in as well
um so yes as I predicted all three of us
have slightly different answers
as well yeah right
um all right there are a ton of
questions here uh thank you all for for
putting these in we're going to try to
get to as many
um
uh many as possible so uh let's see so
maybe for for Rosie for the Fab
technology are there other factors that
should be considered in selecting the
right Fab beside it besides what you
talked about binding affinity and
changes of function of the protein are
there other things that should be
considered
um
um Fabs from these screens I've had up
to 40
um come through and sometimes those Fabs
will bind to different epitopes and so
sometimes if you want to have it for
example I've had one that Bound in the
cavity where I was predicting that my my
substrate was going to bind right so
that's not really ideal if you want to
get a substrate complex structure and so
in that case you'd then go and do the
epitope inning and you can determine
um which one pointing to a different
episode and then move forward with that
one
um
yeah I would also say that I haven't
observed this myself but I wouldn't be
surprised if if
um different Fabs stabilize different
confirmations of the protein so it may
be
um if once you identify if they have
different epitopes then you may want to
um see if they uh
stabilize different confirmations
um but yeah in terms of rigidity and um
using them for structural biology
they're all on the same backbone and
have been optimized for that so it's
more just on in from what I can think of
right now the epitope
very nice yeah a ton of questions about
the Fab strategy here and I'm trying to
combine them in my mind to at least
condense them so while I'm trying to
think of that uh maybe another question
for from mafus
um
let's see see if I can find one oh
um this one we answered sorry uh
so so you talked about the the detergent
screening or I'm sorry the buffer uh the
victories buffer screening kit
um and there's a question here
to summarize you know there's a lot of
components to it
does someone need to screen all of those
buffers and all of these detergents in
that kit to get a result or is there a
limited protocol uh that can be employed
and that's a great question so yes there
is flexibility so it's recommend 12
please because you can screen 12 bits at
once uh but it depends on the protein
and depends on the buffer of choice so
if you know that your protein is Happy
Within These buffers or from the
literature that this protein is not good
in this buffer you can certainly use
certain buffer from this cleaning kit
and certain also a detergent from the
spinning kit so you can choose based on
your likings or from literature review
all right I think another Fab question
for you Rosie
um there's a ton of them here
um let me start it
so
were you able to collect and process
data any data without
a Fab balancing your protein in terms of
getting good 2D glasses
the problem right uh you get a large
number of particles that also don't have
that bound
um and so we process those as well they
did not go to high resolution in this
case
um
I also and you know other sort of
strange things can happen as well when
using the nanoder system like multiple
monomers can go into one Nano disk and
um that can bump one Fab off or the
other
um
so yeah in my case I haven't been able
to
um I'm yeah I but I do know that there
are other situations where you wouldn't
need if you've got a very sort of Rock
Solid protein or
um it's forming a dimer or tetramer or
other sort of oligoma then
um you might be able to get high
resolution without the Fab
um but
um for this protein and I think for ones
that have large amounts of flexibility
or conformational change large
conformational changes it's a little
more
um challenging
right here's I think another question
that we can probably pose to
the two of you and maybe you also get
different answers uh so summary you know
this person is trying to reconstitute
their membrane protein into peptidiscs
uh after being extracted to detergents
um but we see this you know this process
of being able to remove the excess
detergent from uh from a solution uh are
there other methods or what are the best
methods to to sort of try to remove
excess detergents after reconstitution
in other memetics they mentioned
dialysis SEC biobeads uh any others
maybe we'll start with you Rosie uh that
you can think of
um I mean I've always just used bio
beads within an overnight incubation
with biobeads
um and it's worked pretty nicely
um yeah all I can think of other than
that is to have a detention exchange
before the extraction if you're having
an issue trying to extract but then
that's always adding in another step
right so that's you know always
introduce problems in time
um yeah
uh and maybe to you my first any uh
anything that you can think of besides
the three that I mentioned in terms of
removing excess detergent from a from a
solution uh so yes there is for another
method for nanotics formation is is you
just dilute the sample
uh so you added lipid and you added the
isca full proteins and you dilute your
protein in detergent without detergents
adding buffers so it will dilute and the
detergent will be diluted and the
protein will be more reconstituted into
the lipid nowadays so that is another
type of method but I think biobus is
preferable because it does a good job
because it absorbs detergent by Time by
over the time it's not a harsh process
for the protein and its mild process so
little bit accents between a detergent
and then lipid and then detergent little
bit more so it's not a harsh process so
but yeah there are some other methods
also to check that
great
uh Rosie are you tired of answering Fab
questions yet because
uh so
is uh
the question is if the Fab finalized for
the structure determination affected the
function and or stabilized it in a
particular confirmation uh and then sort
of as a corollary where several Fab
screen for function first before
deciding on the final Fab
so the question is are the fads
affecting the function and
yeah are they locking it into a
particular confirmation and or affecting
the function of the person yeah no I
didn't do that myself but I think it's a
great idea because it if you've got a
good functional essay set up for your
protein of interest and you know how to
you know how to read out different
conformational states or substrate
binding or inhibitor binding or whatever
then I think that that's a great place
to start to see if you can you know you
know Whittle out those ones that are
going to bind to your substitute binding
site
um before actually putting them on a
grid I think that's a great idea
um yeah there are a ton of questions
here uh let's see so I think a follow-up
question to something you mentioned
before Rosie uh about multiple membrane
proteins in in one nanodisc uh and the
question is how do you know if your
nanodisc has two or three membrane
proteins and and how does it affect what
you see in cryo-em in terms of
resolution of particles
so when I when I did see I mean in this
case I could like first of all the Nano
to size changes right they can expand or
contract which is what allows this to
happen in the first place and so I could
see multiple
um they weren't highly resolved with
nice trans membranes like I showed you
before but you could see
um
multiple protomas within there and I
mean in this case I
I don't believe that this is a real like
dimer or tetramer or whatever case
whatever the case was
um because of it not happening in um not
getting that same size saluted when I
have the protein level say a lower
concentration or
um at like in a detergent screen
beforehand it came off at a retention
time that's more reminiscent of a
monomer
um but yeah you can pretty much just see
it by either the size of the nanodisc
and you can see the I think in in that
paper that we put out that I actually
did include the different
um
the different 2D classes the ones that
have
um
a Fab bound no Fab bound
um so you can take a look there in the
extended daughter if you want to get an
idea
all right
like the unlike the msps the sample Gene
actually can get any any radius they
want so in case of my experience with my
protein that there was in Native members
there as a dimer so they can actually
like in total it was like around 500
kilowatt alternative protein big Protein
that's supposing can take them as one
and the resolution it depends on the how
direct binding or how many interface of
interaction there with each other or in
simple how flexible is the interaction
if their interaction is rigid the
resolution will be higher and it always
help to make a bigger complex for crying
but if they are flexible and rotate with
each other then it will be difficulty
with the alignment and it will be
difficult to get high resolution data
so we are nearing the top of the hour
and unfortunately there is still a lot
of questions left to be answered so I
will mention that you know anything that
we did not have time for uh during this
q a session we will answer offline via
email uh I do want to take the time here
to to again thank both Rosie and
Matthews for for participating in this
webinar and uh and really thank uh thank
all of you I think we had you know quite
a number of people uh attend this and
probably the most questions I've seen
come in from an audience uh so it's just
more reason that we would uh I think we
have to do this again uh in the near
future uh so again thank uh thank you
Rosie thank you mafus and uh thank all
of you for attending this webinar and uh
and I hope everyone has a great rest of
the day
thank you Eddie
yeah thank you